[Music]
consider yourself warned reading also
how bland is this prophecy only a bright
can control the power of the wand
sounds more like instructions on a board
game than an ancient text but the wand
may only be used when the player rules a
three or a seven or each time Tolkien
rolls over in is great what kind of
mythical creature is this depicting I
know about orcs and elves but where are
the upright-walking lizard people
located on this planet graffitis
position also we get it the orcs
represent the history of racism in
america the metaphor is already so on
the news i basically have to cross my
eyes to see it my favorite AWA song oh
so now this is dialogue from a 2017
movie you sure are spending a lot of
time on this relationship that will
barely come up again five years I'm
going to retire close to retirement
cliche I am the city alright save you
dime fairy lives don't matter today did
he really just say fairy lives don't
matter please tell me I'm imagining all
this I wonder if it was at this point
that Will Smith thought to himself maybe
accepting that role in Django Unchained
wouldn't have been all that bad our
fairies not sentient beings in this
universe did we just witness a murder
should we all start clapping our hands
do you think you could get a burrito and
watch my back like every other cop hold
on a second there Big Willie if I
remember correctly you're the one who
was playing around on your cell phone
not paying attention to the orc with the
rifle directly in front of you the
problem wasn't him watching your back it
was you watching your front so this is a
society that has evolved enough for
co-ed locker rooms but they still have
problems with diversity and she got it I
got a dude in my car the whole world is
watching I didn't ask for it don't want
it but I don't get a vote
however Ward will yell about it in a
locker room full of people whom he might
not agree with while his partner who is
right outside can hear everything
my ancestors killed them by the
thousands in Russia this movie does a
wonderful job and fleshing out its
characters take racist Nick racist in
here he's racist seriously I haven't
seen this much over-the-top antagonism
in the movie since higher learning also
here comes the typical kind of
exposition that makes this story better
suited for a TV show than a movie with
all the history and mythology of how the
society came to be it's impossible to
cram it into a two-hour movie
satisfactorily
[Laughter]
even in an alternate world where we live
amongst mythical creatures the kick me
sign joke is still a goddamn thing also
these people walking the opposite
direction would have no reason to turn
around to even see it in the first place
also also this is apparently the
funniest kick me signs since William
Pitt the Younger affixed one upon the
right honourable Frederick North in
February of 1783 hey guys how can we
show these orcs are super strong I know
we can have him lift a truck so it
couldn't get his soccer ball that he
could easily have reached without
someone lifting the truck geez bill why
do you always suggest things that make
the idea sound stupid okay that's how
we're doing it have the or clip the
truck so the kid can get the soccer ball
do you bill also how does a race that
can lift a truck in the air like this
wind up being oppressed and ghettoized
with this kind of power lead to
dominance as cultures develop
wouldn't it be much more likely in a
world like this that the humans were the
ones used in oppressed I need to know if
you're a cop first fallen or first was
war just hoping they would conveniently
come upon some cop on orc violence so he
could ask this demeaning question to his
partner
wait is that cop a centaur how does that
even work wouldn't the existence of
centaurs change almost every single
thing about the way this world works do
they have special cars for when they
don't want to gallop the 30-mile zone
does every restroom have special centaur
stalls
shouldn't doors and other spaces be
larger to accommodate them so all of
human history happened the same magical
creatures didn't change anything the
problem with this movie is that it
doesn't want to build a world as much as
borrow one eternal affairs
that's right off and a long let's review
kids does anyone in this movie just say
hi before they go into a full rant or
asshole mode which is fine you let me
get him to it these guys are internal
affairs aren't they supposed to be the
most straight-laced guys on the force
who do you call when internal affairs is
dirty
is there an internal internal affairs
affairs how long you been in Sheol
delight discount John Goodman if you're
gonna play stupid games you're gonna win
stupid prizes like a copy of this movie
they're gonna bring back the Dark Lord
fairy fucking tales but fairies are real
here right so is this saying now in
reference to real things saying this
should make as much sense in this world
as saying things like horse tails or
babbling tails err
she's an inferno coven leader she's
bright roll credits
luckily when this guy died he managed to
stick his arm out of this slot and drop
the gun so that Nick and ward could
confirm his death from behind the car
imagining this dude's death is hilarious
yes Joel or curtain shows an early
aptitude for cinema sins but I'll take
it one step further how have you not
even called it in yet right apparently
went to the JJ Abrams School of lenss
flaring which is exactly why it makes no
sense that this is the only or con the
force race is one thing but these
creatures basically have superpowers so
why would you not use them no Shrek
Locke this movie wants to use Jacobi is
Connor relief but if all the laughs are
because he's a naive idiot should we
really be rooting for him to stay on the
force I'm just saying if the movie had
been named after him it would have been
called dim instead who are you the
original title of this movie was alien
nation and the goblet of Fifth Element
fire speaking elvish I don't speak
elvish why seriously I wouldn't the
entire world speak elvish they've been
around for thousands of years and have
presumably wielded wealth and power the
entire time
the elvish pronoun game is just as
annoying as the human one by the way why
does every mother electi could do this
when they're warning somebody that
someone is coming does their fear make
them forget that the person they're
talking to doesn't know shit about the
situation perfect just along bro
then where's Clooney bro where's Clooney
how'd you know it wasn't the mother
fucker shot smell yeah years of
evolution haven't take away her sense of
smell and he's smell different what
human jury would believe me I don't know
maybe the lawyer you hired would get it
or expert on the stand and tell
everybody that works have the ability to
smell things that humans can't and give
a ton of examples and evidence
it's time which is why I'm going to give
you another 60 seconds to figure out a
plan to take us out when we already
decided that you were both going to die
anyway you're left to right if Ward
wasn't gonna go through with killing
Jacoby he should have been able to come
up with a better plan than this he was
down on the street with Jacoby and tikka
a good two three minutes before the
dirty cops showed up they could have run
the fuck out of there quick thinking
Nick guys just gunned down four of your
fellow police officers and you don't
know why so better warned him not to do
that before it's too late a sudden case
of clumsy reload itis strikes again this
works is there some reason these three
cars are driving in this tight triangle
formation isn't this more dangerous and
completely unnecessary
wait is that a dragon now Oh movie you
do not want to be the kind of movie that
teases us with dragons being real and
then just ignore all the ways that would
affect the world around us
alright that's exactly the kind of movie
you want to be why does anybody in
movies ever buy a padlock when you can
open them just by kicking them walls and
wad up right roll credits
no that's just being an asshole
someone's been reading our comments
section it wasn't a non mosh pit path to
take ban keeps playing over automatic
gunfire cliche alright that's not a
cliche because it's absolutely
ridiculous not only does the band keep
playing but these concert attendees
continue to dance after a large fire arm
goes off feet from them either they are
stupid or the movie is stupid let's go
with see all of the above okay fine
apparently smell is a big part of how a
magic fed elf would do his job but why
is he contaminating the crime scene by
touching her face she was that's an
awful lot of assumptions substituting
for actual police work you really picked
up all that from her scent max landis
tweeted that this was his Star Wars does
he think this is his cantina scene and
Star Wars you could feel the depth and
world building in each and every
creature but here one random girls eyes
glitch I'm just saying the comparison
might be a bit of a stretch why would
this guy listen to warp he's not wearing
his uniform dude has no way to know
Ward's a cop huh did this gang know that
warden Nick were in this club they just
changed out of their police uniforms and
walked in here so does someone have a
beacon on them or something come on I
know we all love our gun culture of
fantasies but he's not even shooting at
anybody does he not understand how
bullets work or shrapnel ricochet Mon
you Rick a shame on all of you but you
got
one help me walk again yes wands are
apparently all powerful and can do
anything at all ever in the history of
all things but it's not like just anyone
can use it so why does everybody keep
pretending like it's going to make all
their dreams come true when it's really
more likely to turn them into a pile of
dust after committing some sort of human
rights violation I want to die let's do
it right here right now you ready why is
nobody in movies discussing private
things a few feet away from the enemy
understand the concept of personal
volume control right makes me miss the
simplicity of Marvel movie editing right
runner 2049 apparently part of the
inferni code is that you should stop and
pose in the rain after killing all the
people that actually don't have the
thing you want instead of immediately
chasing the ones that do I love how
these two just keep having their bro
chats while ignoring the person who can
literally smell trouble coming why did
they keep treating her like their elf
sitting instead of finding out more from
her about what the hell is going on oh
so I'm supposed to trust you when you
don't trust me I'm almost sure joel
edgerton is giving a decent performance
here but it's impossible to tell
given the prosthetics I haven't seen a
great actor get buried and blew this bad
since Oscar Isaac got apocalypse too
fearless that's one way to describe
drinking a beer in a grimy ass gas
station bathroom you always know what to
do what you did tonight that's what it
takes for an orc to get blooded an act
of great bravery is he talking about at
the club cuz I remember hiding followed
by a lucky break followed by running
away which one of those was bravery
again oh we friends skip I showed me the
one don't show him if Ward didn't trust
Rodriguez then why did he call him one
all gung-ho do-gooder Rodriguez
basically defied every command word just
gave him before calling the feds but now
at the critical juncture he decides
Ward's right I won't give the location
until he says so in order for this to
work don't they have to already know
where he is and what killing one cell
tower in LA actually kill a specific
signal not sure why the elves need the
magic wand when they have guns with the
best timing ever help chicks somehow
emerges from the car in the perfect
position to shoot away the gun Ward is
trying to get all so why wouldn't she
just shoot wart if he's dead the gun
doesn't really matter a whole hell of
law there is zero chance he didn't just
shoot Layla point-blank in the gut or at
least in a leg I understand the
geography and confinement at this gas
station gives everyone very little
wiggle room but you set the scene here
movie so figure out something better
than this bolt also side note not giving
Layla a dragon tattoo is really a missed
opportunity
I know expert on elf biology but are
they made of
Elam you might as well put her in the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade as far as
she floats after that throw cheap
shelving at gas stations makes for
perfect cover against bullets is this
car doing a doughnut in this small ass
convenience store
damn this with this flammable it's
amazing it hasn't been hit already
considering the amount of bullets that
have been fired in the sink in Fernie
inferno Jesus Christ I mean this is some
totally random part of town yet these
orcs knew that ward Nick and Tico would
be running away from bloodthirsty elves
right here right now like some bad Jesus
Jones concert but I need you to return
to your vehicles and drive home safely
this tactic has not worked in 9000 706
cop movies that came before this one but
you know what they say if in the first
10,000 you don't succeed try try again
I need you to take your fat Shrek
looking ass back to your vehicle and
drive double come to Fiona wait even
Shrek is a real movie here well that's
awkward
Shrek must be this universe's song of
the south varnish oh come on Nick that's
such a lie once he looks up his ass
he'll know you weren't telling the truth
where are we then man where are we then
does every Church in this world come
equipped with a bottomless Balrog pit or
just this one just this one then also
how all these candles stay lit is there
a candle guy that prepares for big
events like this you didn't break you
deserve to be blooded just because the
movie uses the word blooded many many
times doesn't mean the viewers are any
closer to understanding what the fuck it
means are you not sure how this stands
up in the scale of being an or but
Jacobi's an average cop at best in fact
the only thing he seems to be good at is
getting his ass kicked here's some dumb
David Ayer bull right here your cop
needs saving make sure in an earlier
scene that the cop saves the person who
will be responsible for saving the cop
later this is training day all over
again they use work machina this would
be a great scene if it meant anything
however there's still 30 minutes left in
the movie and there's a magic wand close
by so movie isn't fooling anyone with
its main character death bullsh wait a
second where did she have that hidden
was the wand in her arm skin do all of
us have arm pockets is this why Legolas
never ran out of arrows
also this is the case why doesn't the
movie make it so that we can see it
better that could have been a cool
reveal but instead just ends up
completely confusing
why do wands drip in this world it's
that an effect of magic I'm just saying
if I had a drippy wand I'd definitely
get it checked out
I guess if you're ripping off every
movie ever made the Bible isn't much of
a stretch also why are they kneeling
before him he was raised from the dead
magic wand not because he's orc Jesus
shouldn't they be kneeling before tika
they're in kearney they destroyed the
Illuminati a hundred years ago so Shrek
movies exist but the national treasure
movies don't how dare you Landis how
dare you I'm sorry no she didn't I mean
yeah she did but no she didn't why would
she need an assassin to do this job for
why would she give an assassin her wand
to do the job when a number of other
things could have been used to kill her
why would she give her most prized
possession in the plan to resurrect the
Dark Lord to kill a Briton training why
wouldn't Leila's henchman just attack
now had they not got walking through
walls out of their system for the day
one must be a good time to use the magic
wand guns have done zero to stop the
elves this entire movie is every fantasy
movie since Return of the King having a
competition on how many endings they can
have I'll just leave Nick hanging here
there's no way he can cut my plans now
so real sister or just you know
Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants sword
away does the movie explain do we care
the movie has stated on multiple
occasions that humans can be brights so
why is this impossible improbable sure
but impossible is a bit of a stretch and
honestly if Layla had seen any movie
ever this turn of events really
shouldn't have surprised her sorry I
promise oh yeah the prophecy prophecies
are basically the screenwriters crutch
when all the ex maken isn't pure luck
things happen the prophecy you might as
well say that none of these people have
freewill either so earlier when you said
you needed a lot of training to use a
wand was that just pronunciation
training because Ward seems to have
picked this up pretty quick ooh
all right he's married I don't care if
you got orc skin or human skin
if you grab metal and fire that hot
you're gonna have melted skin oh it's
sweet that the orcs have accepted him
and that he's their Savior and all but
how exactly did they even know he was
here all right and those sorry to
interrupt this Abbot and orcs telo
routine actually no I'm not it's way too
long it wasn't funny to begin with movie
has countless mentions with the Dark
Lord but never gives us the Dark Lord
you have my sword I do have my bow my ox
Lord I think you were a little hard on
the beaver
so was that Haskell Wally and miss
cleaver I do believe in fairies I do I
do
[Music]
don't tase me bro don't I need to know
if you're a cop first born or first are
you a Mexican or a mexican't well then I
guess we're gonna miss the good old days
of our good old days when people were
killed by other people my son turns its
colors tonight
[Music]